This actually isn't really a question. It's more of a comment. Yeah.
I kind of turned it into a question, I guess. Yeah.
You responded to the comment. Yeah, sure. Anyway,
just want to say quick. Thanks.
I struggle with the daily grind trading days for dollars,
but you helped me make it happen. Yeah, and my comment was like, okay,
well thank you. I guess
because I hope at the same time that you're grinding,
that you're trading, that you're,
I hope that you're not trading days for dollars long term because long term,
that's a losing proposition, right?
If you're grinding and it's not doing something you want to do,
if it's a grind that you can't embrace,
then you've got to find a way out of that. Right? You got to fight. You can't,
Trey,
you don't want to trade days for dollars because dollars don't mean anything.
Days is all you got. So you gotta find a way.
Now, this does not mean you need to be rash about it.
This doesn't mean tomorrow you walk in and I'm not doing this job anymore.
I'm out and now you're broke. No,
don't be rash and don't throw the baby out with the bath water.
But do come up with a longterm plan about what you want to do,
how you want to do it, where you want to do it.
And this might take one year or two years or five years,
it might take five years to get to where you want to be. That's okay.
That's fine. It's,
it's actually kind of cool when you're grinding right now cause you know there's
something that you're working towards in the long run that's actually awesome.
So, but, but you gotta have an exit strategy.
You got to have an exit strategy.
You've got to plan and figure out how much money it's going to take and what are
you going to do? You're going to work two jobs.
I'm going to save all my money right now. I'm going to invest here.
Then pay off my mortgage. Whatever it is you're going to do
so that you can get yourself into a position where you actually enjoy doing what
you're doing. That's what you want.
And the one other cool thing about this, like,
like I say, man, it's cool to grind, man. That's what we're here to do.
You're here doing stuff right?
If you're not doing anything well then what are you doing?
So the other thing that's cool though about grinding and working is,
is that when you get that freedom right, that you work hard for,
it's going to be so much more worth it.
That discipline that you put into place to get to that freedom that you want,
it makes that freedom so much more worth it. So I appreciate it.
I'm glad you're grinding. I'm glad you're grinding hard,
but don't just make that trade. It's not a square trade days for dollars,
not a square trade. Get it back under your control. And we've had,
I've actually had some really cool feedback on the podcast of people that have
hit me up and said, hey, I, you told me to plan an exit strategy.
I wish I could find a guy said, you told me to plan an exit strategy. He's like,
that was whatever, nine months ago I saved my money. I just did this.
Now I'm in another business. I'm kicking ass. Thank you. Right? Yeah.
So it can be done. It's one of the things about cool about being a human being.
You've got free will. You can make stuff happen to go make it happen.